[Music]
hello reject nation
we are at amc
we're talking to our phones right now
because it's so echoey here that this
will help the audio
um we just got done watching no time to
die
and
this is first reactions
i'm having a bit of difficulty uh
processing
some stuff that happens in this movie i
heard there were going to be surprises
i heard like a number of things i heard
i was obviously no spoilers there wasn't
anything about the ending but a lot of
people were saying the ending is
divisive and i was like what the hell
could a bond baby yeah yeah that's gonna
be that i haven't seen in a different
bond movie before yeah
we watched the ending and john and i
both looked and he took the last hack
like oh my god i didn't see that coming
they're really doing this yeah so that's
all we'll say because we don't want to
make the focus of that even though when
this movie's done that will be all
you're thinking about most likely it
will overshadow the experiences leave it
at that here's my basic thoughts on how
i felt about the movie
i thought the first i want to say like
hour hour 20
very strong very different very engaging
and the last half i
it wasn't gripping me as much in the
last half i'm not going to say there's
not things in it that i didn't like okay
here's the basic summary first half
wow this is really engaging this is
really good
second half
it's kind of like becoming like a by the
numbers bond movie also this is this is
daniel craig's last bond movie and then
like
the last act has moments of holy crap
what is happening right now that's the
basic summation right i feel like we're
working on him on the same people in the
movie yeah i think we're on the same
page about this generally yeah i would
agree it's like it starts out in a
pretty exciting manner where yeah you
know you can kind of get the sense for
what carrie fukunaga is bringing to the
table with this movie and there is a lot
of really punchy action there is a lot
of you know gripping context there's a
big convoluted plot and whatnot and then
yeah once it finally gets to being a
bond movie and really settles into its
whole big villain thing which kind of
happens later on in the movie than you
might expect then yeah it starts to feel
like okay we're doing a lot of the bond
classic tropes which some of which work
because you know every time you get a
new eccentric villain and a new
eccentric layer there's fun to be had
there but yeah it does kind of level out
until
okay i kind of know what to expect until
the end you know comes up and then
that's when the surprises kick back in i
mean i'll say that i i feel like the
action sequence sequences here are
probably stronger there's a variety of
action scenes here and i felt like harry
fuconago wanted to definitely capture
like
difference like really take advantage of
the specific types of stages and
sequences and the stunt performers and i
think it's probably the best action out
of any of the specific daniel craig
movies so probably any bond because
honestly
it's the best action yeah so it's
probably the best action i've seen in
any bomb movie i'd like to revisit
casino royale before officially
declaring that and i would say too that
in terms of like an acting performance
daniel craig
he's just as committed and as good here
as he as he was in casino royale yeah
he's great in this the film's gonna
challenge you on some things in terms of
the bond character we're not the biggest
bond enthusiasts we've seen a lot of
james bond movies we haven't seen every
james bond movie there are things here
that take place where you're like
oh that's going to piss off some bonds
yeah yeah there are a few plot choices
and also character choices flat out
elements in bond the character that are
i've heard people calling this the
sensitive bond which it's a tower bond
it's a tower but it's more dour than i
was expecting based off of that
assessment of sensitive bond but there
is yeah also a more sensitive layer to
the character that i am curious to see
how people respond to because to me
again it's a movie that seems for this
franchise that is sort of built upon not
making too many bold choices
specifically about the character yeah
this movie does try to do that that's
why i was thinking that the last half
had this weird mix of you're doing the
the new challenging things that not
every bond fan is going to get on board
yeah but trying to deliver it in a very
bond-esque package i didn't think i'd
ever be compelled to talk spoilers about
a bond before but this movie does things
to challenge the audience on it that i
feel there is an argument to be made for
why it is appropriate specifically for
the daniel craig franchise for the
choices they decide to go down here
because
i've always thought casino royale was a
bit of this weird
wiggle room for the fact it was like
it's a bond origin movie it's a prequel
yet it takes place in modern day it
doesn't go back to the 60s to like you
know like do the prequel before all the
other plots you know something like that
so i felt like they have more liberty to
get more emotional and serialized and
and [ __ ] like that that being said
though there are things that i can
totally see you know how they talked
about like luke skywalker
when he takes the watch from q and
throws it over his shoulder yeah i don't
need these gadgets cute and i also
thought that they fleshed out the
characters
pretty much all around they made
everyone much more human in ways that
kind of surprised me
like the return of ben wishaw's q he was
great but really the standouts i i
thought were
surprisingly
because i thought spectre was boring as
hell and i couldn't remember jack about
the madeleine character
only like necessary details to follow
this movie and she was great what was
her name
yeah she's fantastic here she's
fantastic i cared a lot about her i
thought she was wonderful i did too i i
thought also lashana lynch had a lot of
presence anna de armas they show her in
the trailer i'm gonna tamper some
expectations here she's not in the movie
a lot but when she's there it's a
delight yeah she's obvious she brings
something refreshing yeah to it very
invigorating and some of that bond fun
that you and a different kind of fun too
yeah there's a certain sense of ensemble
that this movie hits that i thought was
quite fun and satisfying yeah i liked
all the new players as well as the
returning players like everybody got
some moments to shine and i really liked
them all as a unit both when they were
at odds and when they were finally all
working together you know even freaking
ray finds was great and that you see
jeffrey wright the watcher return
it's weird to see naomi harris in a
movie last week and this year here
finish what if this week you can see
jeffrey
and jeffrey wright this is my favorite
of felix that we've gotten from him and
felix is really i mean
that and casino royale like oh well yeah
i mean it's hard to top him in casita
royale
malek i was actually surprised we didn't
talk much about the movie when it was
done but when he first showed up i was
like oh damn that robbie molly he's
bringing a lot it just means he has a
presence but then as it progressed i was
like man this guy is kind of dull
boring
i felt like they they felt like they
needed to write some super villain
yeah it was not really that engaging
even though i felt like romney malik was
really trying to bring the heft he's
doing everything that you would want a
bond villain performer to be doing and
he's got you know a lot of the
eccentricities but yeah when it comes
right down to just the execution of it i
almost felt like that was an area where
maybe they should have gone a little bit
more unique made a choice that isn't
he's very subdued in his performance
style for this particular character and
for whatever reason i kind of got only
about what i expected from the villain
from rami malik which is a bummer
because i think generally he's a
terrific actor but this didn't show me
anything like special or like he was
taking the gloves off and having fun
portraying the bond villain so much not
necessarily that he has to be having fun
but uh that was an element that left me
wanting something more satisfying rather
than like scratching my head and
wondering how i might feel as some of
the other elements did i would still say
though overall i don't know if i'd i
mean casino royale is like top tier i
can't i can't nothing beats that for me
to be honest the question is does it
beat skyfall yeah that's the question
doesn't mean skyfall i think it takes
more bold choices it's more daring and
there's things about this that even if i
only watch this movie once i'm gonna
remember forever yes exactly yeah and i
think
for me that would be the one thing that
pushes it over and i know i was gonna
piss off somebody watch this movie
that'd be the one thing that pushes this
over skyfall for me was like for sure
i'm gonna remember [ __ ]
even if i only watch this one time
there's things that they do here in
terms of action visually really even
with the sound design obviously it's a
bomb move there's gonna be a lot of
explosions
and one thing that i love is a very
unique choice that i thought was kind of
a a replay here if there was like a
really loud explosion that caused like
that ear ring and the way they handled
the um the way the audits the muffling
of this
yeah
slowly
they use sound design to make it more
immersive there are some action scenes
here that i just thought were brilliant
oh yeah the bomb music was also really
good in this movie it was vermont zimmer
and so there was a lot of action scenes
where it sounds exactly like the dark
knight which is funny because skyfall
seemed to apel off in the dark knight
and this one makes you think of dark
knight because of the music but it has
like that bond flavor to it too it's
really good it's really good
i like the dark knight i'd say like this
movie i probably like it i like a lot
about it but there are definitely times
where i was like i feel like i should be
feeling something but i'm really not
feeling anything yeah yeah and that kind
of went on for like a while yeah i'm
really curious as to how i'm gonna feel
about this in like a few days time
because i agree it's like there are
certain choices it makes that personally
usually me as a viewer i'm like cool try
something different take a swing do
something bold and maybe if it doesn't
work for everyone at least breathe some
new life into this series and i think
yeah they do successfully do that to
some degree and then you know the rest
is about uh kind of how the more
standard parts uh complement all that
and yeah like coming out of the theater
i think i may have been a bit more
enthused off the bat over skyfall but i
think there are aspects of this that
might be a bit more admirable in terms
of skype that's have to like excite you
yeah this movie doesn't this movie isn't
trying to it's like everybody has
exciting action but the rest of the
movie is not exciting it's not trying to
be as slick as all those other movies
are like
that's another aspect i'm curious to
note because you know a lot of fun when
there's not action it's hard to interact
no no for sure because there is a
certain element of energy and rhythm
coming out of especially the direction
but yeah it's not like a movie that
stops to have fun except for in
character scenes where there's like
dialogue humor yeah and yeah it's not
doing like too much hyper elegant flashy
like camera work and stuff like that and
as you see in the trailer it's a love
story
it's like venom
venom like the re-carnage
but yeah that's our thoughts
family man
i'd give it a recommendation and i'm
just so fascinated to know what people
have to say because uh see it for
yourselves yeah that wow that that final
act all right guys thanks for being here
we'll see you guys soon
[Music]